tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored a
world exclusive interview he was
Hollywood's oscar-winning Golden Boy
until his career collapsed in Scandal
Cuba Gooding Jr one on one
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored good evening from London
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored
tonight Cuba Gooding Jr one on one
Cuba Gooding Jr was Hollywood's Golden
Boy boxed off his belters like boys in
the hood and A Few Good Men took him to
the top tier of Tinseltown an
oscar-winning role in Jerry Maguire made
him iconic landed in one of Cinemas most
iconic catchphrases
Cruz I love you brother I love you man
the golden statue was the beginning of
The Golden Boys unraveling
anxious to protect his Superstar status
he turned down roll off the role
rejecting Spielberg for Amistad Michael
Mann for collateral even turned down the
lead and the last king of Scotland the
role which Native Forest Whitaker the
Academy's top of War
and after a lost decade in the Hollywood
Shadows he lost his shine once and for
all facing a Spate of allegations about
inappropriate behavior with women this
year he confessed to charges of forcible
touching with two other [ __ ] of
non-consensual contact narrowly escaping
jail now Cuba Gooding Jr wants a shot at
Redemption tonight he'll make his case
and it will all be uncensored
well I'm joined Now by Cuba Gooding
Junior Cuba thank you very much for
coming on the show of course Pierce
thank you for having me I'm glad to be
here last time I interviewed you was
quite a few years ago now probably uh 10
or 11 years ago the butler yeah and it
was a great film and I love the
interview and you're with Oprah and all
these others that were doing it and your
career seemed great your life seemed in
a good place everything was good in the
world of Cuba Gooding Jr very different
circumstances for you when we meet today
when you look back on everything that's
happened to you in the last few years
what do you feel about it
I mean we have
we have the whole show to talk but uh
you know in 2013 separated from my wife
of 20 something years uh 2000
17 18 my father passes away suddenly
um
and then uh you know it's it's it's one
of those moments in my life where I was
trying to numb the pain so I would
you know just kind of
go out and not worry about a thing you
know and uh
and it uh it it opened me up to a lot of
um interactions with people in clubs and
bars and whatnot
and I you know it's the world knows I
pled guilty uh for uh the count of for
uh forcible touching
uh kiss the waitress so that's that I'm
not here to
shame anybody or to you know take any of
these women who've you know made their
uh statements but it is one of those
moments where I look back and I say how
did you find yourself in this
scenario in this situation so I reflect
on that day at the bubbles party in New
York City sitting with my girlfriend uh
and uh at a booth with people coming and
going
you know I I've been doing a lot of
karaoke I was on the west end stage
doing Chicago the musical and then I
took it to Broadway so I find myself
with a microphone singing and
entertaining crowds and at this
particular day we had a group of people
who had come up to us anyway
um a young lady came and sat uh next to
uh my girlfriend and
um she said she was a huge fan of Snow
Dogs
and uh we conversed and then when our
our group left
I I believe I gave her a kiss on the
hand and we left and my girlfriend
stopped her from coming and I think that
upset her or whatever
and this is all on tape which is the
funniest thing and so you see her follow
us around the the club
and eventually I because I had to get on
a plane
said goodbye to my group and left and
you see her look for me go up to a
security guard make a statement to him
and then the police show she makes a
statement to them they review the tapes
the tapes they review every moment that
they can for the time I was there they
don't see any of the claims that she
made
and then the
Special Victims Unit
um
Personnel from the DA's office shows
and they explained to this person what
they saw on the tapes
and the person obviously
um went ahead with uh
putting on a warrant for my arrest
so when I land in La my lawyer calls me
and says you got to come back some woman
said that you touched her breast and I
said when and where
so to make a long story short
you know one of the police officers
somebody in the in the police department
released the mug shot and they were
fired they released a video
that showed exactly what I explained to
you on the video
but I had been um told that when I show
up to the police station that they'll um
they'll they'll have to drive me to the
courthouse to see the judge and there's
press in the front so they'll take me
out back so I said fine and we walked
out back and it was the world as you saw
me and handcuffs going in the car and
that moment kind of started this
snowball siren effect of the D.A
weaponizing the police force and I get
it
I'm uh you know uh at home
I'm I'm seeing all of the the news
accounts
and then
um what I've come to find later
is that the DA's office went to the
people who work with the uh the Tau
group and they said we want all the
footage
of any time Cuba's ever been in your
nightclubs and at the time I had a
friend who was a promoter
so I was at the bubbles party I was at a
another uh two other establishments of
there and they literally combed
everything to see if they could find any
other instances of impropriety
so they found another clip
where I had uh gestured towards a
waitress as I was leaving touched her
back went to give her a high five she
said don't pinch my butt that was the
second indictment
and then the third one
at the end of an evening where the
waitress uh who gives me um
my bill
I gave her a big tip so she comes back
you see her she kisses him on the cheek
so I turn and I give her a kiss on her
lips
so
now fast forward to the pandemic where
all Court activity stops
for over a year year and a half
you know we all just reflected on where
we had been the D.A had continued to ask
for women to come forward with any
interactions like a siren class 30 women
came 30 women one of them was in St
Louis and I think
I was there for two hours I was you know
the uh Mark McGuire hit uh home run 7071
I threw out the pitch
so you know I I I don't know I think
they are it is what it is again
um and then eventually when the courts
opened
my lawyers said listen
we could go to trial and we can you know
show the video footage of all three
instances they can show you partying and
singing in your karaoke
and they can you know go through this
stuff or we can take this deal of you
because you did Kiss the Girl and I said
100 and they have this thing called the
repleter so when I
and I heard you're in your opening that
I pled guilty and all these the guilty
charges for a violation of forcible
kissing and
after six months of therapy
the judge re-pleated it down to a
violation I've had violations
it was first uh harassment yes correct
so
yeah here we are here we are I mean look
yeah you've obviously you've not done
interviews so it's all just come
splurging out I wanted to let you say
your bit no I get it because you've not
spoken about this and so you've been
thinking about nothing else and
obviously it all just comes out and it's
very centered on your mind when I've
looked at everything that's happened to
you in totality yeah
would it be fair to say when you look
back at your behavior in that period
that you were
clubbing a lot oh I was a [ __ ] yes I'm
drinking along again and I don't do
drugs I don't do cocaine or anything
right but you were drinking a lot
partying a lot yeah and you were
behaving
by what most people would consider
certainly today to be inappropriate
towards a lot of women it just didn't
cross your mind that your behavior was
not inappropriate it wasn't that it was
my behavior was focused towards women it
was I was Carefree in front of groups
and crowds of people if you see on that
footage of me kissing the waitress I
also kissed male bartenders I was
high-fiving people going with bottle
service so yes if it was if that is an
appropriate thing yeah I mean some of
the allegations that women made and I
want to make it clear yeah no charges
were brought on these right and I'm you
know like I know that in Hollywood a lot
of very famous stars they get a lot of
false allegations so I'm not presuming
any of these to be true or otherwise
I've never things that led to charges
but there seemed to just be a pattern of
of claims you know a woman in 2001 he
robbed his groin and pelvis hard against
her bottom 2003 put his hand on a
woman's buttocks and squeezed it without
a picture together another bar in 2006
bit a woman on her shoulder twice and
thrust his pelvis against her another
woman in the Hard Rock in Las Vegas 2007
lick kissed her licked her face grabbed
her bottom and so on I'm going to go
through them all
um as I say I don't know the veracity of
each individual claim but there were a
lot of women who came forward who all
made claims that you just behaved in a
way that was inappropriate and bordering
on a form of assault now I'm not here to
relitigate what's happened to you you
pled guilty and you've been dealt with
and you apologize for your conduct to
any women that you'd 100 100 I own that
right so what to all these women
without wanting to go over each
individual right to every woman who's
made a claim like this against you for
just inappropriate touching of some
description what is your message to them
well it's like I said in court I don't
want anybody to feel that they've been
treated inappropriately or harassed by
me in any way I love my fans I love men
and women all of my fans
um
you know I look I look back on my life
okay uh and I spoke about this when I
did boys in the hood we were homeless
for a while in Orange County living in a
car and my mom found a women's abuse
shelter
for us to find refuge in
and the the rules of the in Santa Ana
California
and the rules of the shelter is that you
can only stay there for not more than 48
hours before you're transferred to the
next facility and at the time I was
around 14 15 years old and I remember
I remember these women coming in and and
the conductor of the facility said you
have to go in your room because they
didn't want any male presence when they
came to the living room area of this
house
and to think that women
would think that I would cause that
heartache to them is devastating to me
and I I saw the effects the trauma that
these women had went through so I I take
that very very seriously and I I look at
a lot of these things to me as
um you know it's just it's it's a time
for growth and reflection
still to come more from my exclusive
interview with Cuba Gooding Jr despite
the harm to me Cuba Gooding Jr walks
away from the court a free man without a
record
it's like it never happened truth
truth peers
this video footage of it there was no
contact with her breasts that's the
truth
[Music]
are you are you ashamed of your baby in
that period I think I think yeah at some
of some of those the boisterous thing
the thing about me too is a lot of
people when they when they meet me they
come to know my energy they always think
oh he's got to be on some drug it's too
much energy well look I mean I mean the
role you won the Oscar for in German
Maguire was one of the old-time great
roles one of my favorite characters ever
you know in that movie
um but people would look at this and say
well that's not an excuse for the kind
of behavior that you refuse to do and
indeed that you've admitted to doing
that you may have had tough stuff in
your life you may have had a tough
moment when you split from your wife
your father done all these things of
course they're hard things which people
go through in life but it doesn't turn
most people into what you became for
that period so I I so what do you say
the answer to that is you know
it's you have to live in your truth and
I know in my truth I didn't
mean to disrespect anyone and I know in
my truth and again on the videos
My Truth I'll be honest so let me I've
always had a problem with the phrase my
truth because to me as a journalist this
is the truth you're right so the fact
let's strike when people start talking
about magic it sounds a bit like Meghan
Markle with Oprah Winfrey's like it
gives you a license to say what you want
is this one and I and I totally agree
and I know your situation with Meghan
Markle I know that whole thing so let's
take the word my out there's video
footage of the interactions with these
women
that showed that truth of what happened
and it's funny so I had so many people
come up to me in the street and say I
support you I saw the video blah blah
but the one thing that I found that
really hit me and I said okay now it's
time for me to mention this to talk
about it I mean it's like it's basically
I started in this career loved and
people like oh it's energy nothing's
changing with me but I do have to
address it for what you just said about
my it's not my truth it is the truth but
this one woman commented on on my uh my
my my social media platform she says
thank you for pleading guilty I may be
wrong but I think you are the first in
these sort of cases to do so that is a
courageous move of Integrity I keep
hoping some man with influence will
demonstrate for others how to stand in
accountability make amends learn and
continue to be held in love Truth and
Reconciliation begins with truth so
thank you I hope you are weathering the
storm okay keep standing tall and hope
you will be a front runner of change and
not only that everything appears I pray
and that my mom taught me this when I
was young everything happens in God's
will if you pray it because if you're
doing what you're supposed to be doing
God will take you to them okay but what
would you say for example to Kelsey have
it now she was the one who says you
fondled her breast at the magikar
Rooftop in New York in 2019. you weren't
charged over the incident a decision
that outraged her she said that she was
robbed of justice and she said this the
one thing I was promised in the end was
an apology
in court for what he did to me
and for the opportunity to tell my side
in a victim impact statement since I
wouldn't get my day in court
when it came time to make that apology
Cuba Gooding Jr's exact words were
I'm sorry if I made anyone feel
inappropriately touched
I didn't just feel inappropriately
touched I was inappropriately touched
because of what he did
I have to worry about a guy's intentions
when he talks to me on the bus
I have to worry about where a guy's
hands are when he squeezes past me in
the supermarket
I have to be worried about riding in the
elevator alone with a man because
there's nothing shielding me from
something going wrong
despite the harm to me Cuba Gooding Jr
walks away from the court of free Man
Without a record
it's like it never happened
but can the same thing be said for the
women he did this to
is it like it never happened to me
so the first thing I'll say is what I
already did and I apologize to all my
friends but the second thing is truth
truth peers there's video footage of it
there was no contact with her breast
that's the truth the other impact
statement of the other girl I know if
you're going to read that she said oh
the video footage didn't show him
pinching my butt that was later that's
not true that's not true so I suppose
look I suppose the point I would make to
you given that you've admitted to
a criminal offense right we just have to
put that on the table you did
like I say there were Myriad stories
that came forward and who knows whether
the truth lies because they weren't all
put through a court process right given
your admission yeah do you understand
that you know parking that specific case
to one side and maybe many of the others
but do you accept that this was perhaps
the unintended consequence
of your behavior which you've never
really factored in that actually what
may seem just like casual fun in a club
actually can have real-time effects on
people and again I have to say to your
peers if you see the video footage which
is there and evident and if there was
inappropriate other than the kiss to the
waitress
I wouldn't have been able to to take the
take the kiss to the waitress I wish you
pleaded guilty to right that was
forcibly touching somebody against their
will yes behind my cheek and I grabbed
her and kissed her on the left so 100 so
on that so now here's the thing and now
you just want to be because you saw my
truth will let that go I got attacked
for that I'll say that again but the
truth of me and the waitress is what I
pled guilty to the other charges didn't
happen right or I would have pled guilty
to them that's the truth I hope you
understand that I know I understand that
completely I'm really talking about it
seems to me what you're saying is that
for a number of reasons in your life
you started drinking heavily partying
heavily perhaps losing your way a bit
and that in that period
there may be a lot of interaction with
women's you didn't intend to be harmful
right totally but that actually for a
lot of them it seems they they did feel
harmed by it and I wouldn't want anybody
to feel unappropriate uh that I was
inappropriate anyway and and like I told
you you know being home for two years
staring at yourself going how did you
put yourself in the situation what were
you feeling when you were going through
that period I mean sitting on your own
you're Cuba Gooding Jr yeah you're a
globally famous man you've been in some
of the greatest movies ever made you
were a Hollywood Superstar with
everything that goes with it and then
suddenly you're there you're sitting
there in a pandemic you're locked down
you're locked down with your thoughts
about your own behavior and the kind of
person you are what did you deduce about
where you've got to in life well I was
like everybody else the only
Communications that anyone had with me
was through my lawyers and headlines
that certain media Outlets would love to
Splash and the things that were said and
it's so funny it's like I look at I look
at when a lawyer speaks on your behalf
they never say that attorney said this
or that they they only say Cuba Gooding
Jr says her breasts were too small or
Cuba Gooding Jr did this or that and it
was it was horrifying it was horrifying
because
your words are not your words they're
someone else's and then that becomes the
headline whether it's true or not that's
what people see and that's what people
believe so that period was one of those
times where I just had to
you know like everyone else I had to sit
there and and and and reflect on it and
hopefully was a very emotional time for
you oh 100 100 it's you know
I mean I mean you must have felt like
you'd lost everything yeah well it's
more than that it was like you don't
want to let down those who have
supported you and brought you where
you're at and my family my friends who
are responsible for the success that I
have today uh yeah you feel you feel
guilt you feel a guilt and you and you
get through that and you work on ways to
improve you have you changed yourself I
a hundred percent in what way I it's one
of those things now and it's funny too
because
I don't want this to stop me connecting
with my fans I don't want this to stop
me connecting with the gregarious
behavior in terms of the positive energy
that I have so I I just you know I'm 10
times more aware of what's going on
around me and I just use that as my
focus
you've got three children including a
teenage daughter yes wait Mason
your daughter's 17 I think is that right
I'm sure I've got a daughter as well
yeah 11.
when you have a teenage daughter in
particular I would think this kind of
Scandal must hit particularly hard at
home yeah what kind of conversations
have you had to had with her it's it's
one of those things where
you have to
allow every experience in your life it's
almost like I can't take the positive
the Oscars and the the fame and ignore
the negative it's it's all it's all
encompassing of what where I am today
and who I am today and it's it's you
know it's it's one of those things where
she has to find her own truth in her
moments and I have to be supportive of
Whatever May Come has she forgiven you
for it you know it's one of the
conversations I haven't really had about
her because I think she she just she
showed me so much love you know it's
like on my phones I have two images of
my mom and my daughter and it's one of
those things where
they they remind me of
how the source of my strength which is
family and God and that's it who are the
most important members of your family to
you all of them who when you think about
your behavior and who you answer to if
you like oh the females in your life of
course your mother your daughter your
sister my cousin what's being your
mother's reaction to everyone you know
again she's been really supportive she's
been there through a lot of these
scandalous headlines which again I have
no control over and it's one of those
moments where you just say you know
your reactions affect everybody around
you well next to like Cuba Gooding Jr
reveals which of his famous friends is
stuck by him and the ones who haven't
[Music]
I go from winning an Oscar to having a
walk around Hollywood wherever it may be
with a sex scandal erupting around your
your image if you like what's that
experience like
you know it's it again it's like
it's just one of those aspects of being
someone in the spotlight you can't stand
on stage with an award over your head
and accept that but not accept this and
it's just it's just it is what it is
it's the business that particularly for
someone like you who's got such a you
know your your normal personality is so
bursting with energy and positivity
you're very light the character you
played in Jerry Maguire yeah from my
experience of interviewing you this is
this must have dented a lot of that
self-confidence you had the swagger no
no no I'm still killing it still killing
the game
no but seriously seriously I mean it's
hasn't dented your confidence at all to
me I am who I am I know God's reason why
I'm here I've been given certain gifts
and insights and it's funny because you
you and the media love to speak of the
Scandal and talk about it and oh no and
my thing is is my interactions with the
people you know we have this and we
haven't talked about this company view
it
v-e-u-i-t.com which is like
the I think the answer to a lot of
situations that we we're dealing in
society but one of our uh nft projects
so to speak is this thing called Cuba
goodness which is I've probably taken 10
000
selfies with people around the world and
we're putting out a call for them to
send us any selfie I've ever taken and
in turn receive a piece of this nft so
to me it's like you are who you are as
long as you own who you are and if you
feel like you've done a disservice
you have to grow from it and not repeat
it the stuff that you were you pay
guilty to is you know on the general
scale of crime
most people would not see that as
particularly heinous albeit it was wrong
and inappropriate and you've paid the
price for it but you are facing
potentially far more serious allegations
the Hollywood lawyer Gloria Allred
represents an alleged rape victim so
she's going to proceed with an ongoing
six million dollar civil lawsuit because
Justice wasn't achieved when you've got
your no jail plea deal what's your
response to that you know like I said to
you all of these women came they made
their statements everybody has their
their
um right to speak
what they perceive is their right to
speak about and like you just said it
will be settled in court I I I'm sorry
well I'll give you a parallel so prince
Andrew over here for example kept saying
I'm going to clear my name clear my name
clear my name and at the last minute he
settled with an accuser uh gave her
millions and millions of dollars and
people have drawn their own conclusions
from that notwithstanding he made no
admission of liability right in your
case you did make an admission of
criminal activity and you were convicted
on that basis
um and as that person sent you that that
note
in a way that is laudable to admit what
you did and then to try and
reshape your life and to seek I guess
some form of redemption right which is
where you are now there'll be people
watching this and some might say he
should never be forgiven right it's
disgusting behavior and everything
there'll be others who say actually on
balance
for what he was found guilty of what he
admitted
um he should be given a second chance
we're in a weird time in in the world
yeah it's canceled culture you know
atmosphere where people are very
unforgiving aren't they they're very
quick to destroy people they don't want
to ever give them a chance to come back
right what do you say to those people
about why you should be given a second
chance you know you just said it I don't
have to say it people will think one
thing or they'll think another I'm not
here to convince them that what they
think I can just present myself as who I
am
on The Wider issue of cancer culture
what do you make of it what do you think
of it
that's part of modern society yeah back
in the days of the um star system
they used to have departments
ads uh uh every Studio the Jets dealt
with the image of the celebrity
and it was to make sure that you saw
them with their kids and in the park and
and the studio focused on it and at some
point when the system broke down that
department changed from that to the
reality of Scandal
and then it became fun the housewives of
you know fill in the city and this
divorce and this scandalous
um you know behavior from the celebrity
and that became the business of
Hollywood and now you have the
regurgitation of that into this movement
that's not unlike the McCarthy era where
now they're like if you say or do
anything oh yeah no he's canceled we
move on there's no
uh revisiting how has Hollywood
responded to what's happened to you
particularly since yeah you made your
admission so when you pled guilty what's
been the reaction since has Hollywood
shunned you are all the doors shut are
some open again how has it viewed what
you did it's been a little bit of
everything I feel a little bit of
everything Pierce and the thing with me
is
you know uh it's funny it's like going
back to the media and the headlines I
did this um charity event uh for uh uh
children uh cancer pediatric cancer and
they asked me to sing with the band and
so they gave me a mic I went on stage
and we did this song we raised almost a
million dollars that night and yet the
headline says Cuba jumps up on stage and
starts singing you know Hey Jude which
is not the song I sing I sing Come
Together by The Beatles but that was one
of those things where I get it the
narrative fits for me to be this ogre
but it still doesn't change
not my truth the truth of who I am right
your girlfriend uh Claudine she stood by
you yeah throughout all yeah she was
there she was sitting in between us
right so what is she on my arm the whole
time what does she make of it she thinks
it's ridiculous she absolutely does but
I don't want to speak for anybody else
but me because that's who I'm here your
girlfriend is being around you when some
of these allegations have been made
and she stood by you
is that because she believes you're a
completely innocent man about all these
things or does she just understand you
and think that part of your stick is
your very tactile with people
I think she supports me because she
loves me and I think that she obviously
knows that truth about what happened
that day and and she's you know she's
just a great lady
you're gonna marry him no no I've been
there done that I've I know I shouldn't
say it like that yeah never you never
know but no I I I've uh right now I got
enough taking care of me and and uh my
like I say Piper goes to college and a
very short time I want to make sure she
has
as much support as she has and attention
she she needs for me and uh but it's
hard isn't it for anyone in the public
eye when this happens with kids oh 300
so what do you say to your sons about it
you know my sons and I talk Ad nauseam
about everything like I say Mason turns
26 today Spencer's 28. you have
expensive I have a Spencer yeah Spencer
James Gooding yeah Warriors Warriors
um but we we talk about everything not
just this everything and it's it's
because it's my job to really and I mean
this make them my new and improved
models and that's what I'm focused on do
you teach them to learn from your
mistakes 100 you have to if you don't
learn from your mistake you're going to
repeat it you know and um and it's and
it's it's been my focus now to move my
life ahead in a way that not only helps
me but helps others around me how
all your famous friends reacted to this
have they stood by you have any not
stood by
has it been a bit of both it's it's that
thing where the ones that stood by you
they they communicate with you and the
ones that don't you don't hear from them
so it's it's just I I'd have to assume
the ones I don't hear from don't stand
by me are there any more or I could say
they're standing by me in quiet
solidarity I mean are there any that
really disappointed you with the I won't
do that but I'll tell you about the love
I've seen well I'm asking you to name
people I'm just saying hello I'd like to
name people but I don't want to do it in
a negative way like 50 Cent yes he
reached out to me and he said listen
your your talent is what it is and let's
do something let's let's roll let's make
a show together I love that see that
that must mean a lot when people do that
it's the best one thing you haven't
mentioned to me is acting I mean do you
want to act again
all right well you want to go to that
part of the conversation I I have a
couple of roles I I um
that I've shot right I did this movie uh
this well we'll start with this series
first because I always laugh when I see
this photo but I played the head of the
CIA at 65. right I know I know I know
I'm aging who's that fool this is for a
show called paper Empire and then I play
who's making that
um it's uh Robert Gillings he's wrote
produced it and I think they're shopping
it around now but hopefully when we get
because we launch uh view it in um
in January so we will probably have them
on the platform
um I was you know obviously go back to
Jerry Maguire Tom Cruise has just made
one of the biggest movies of all time
yeah
Maverick it's great have you heard from
him in recent years he's got to come
does Cuba Gooding Junior keep in touch
with his oscar-winning co-star Tom
Cruise I'll find out
[Music]
obviously go back to Jerry Maguire Tom
Cruise has just made one of the biggest
movies of all time yeah
Maverick it was great have you heard
from him in recent years no not in a
while nothing
what'd you say would you like to have
done you know it is what it is I get it
listen do you get it though I don't
think I would get it in that position I
have to get it you know why because like
I said God's will works in my life good
and bad and I have to accept them both
there's this show that we're doing you
know I've had some difficult stuff in my
life over time and I can remember every
single person that put their hand out
for me yeah and I can remember even more
everyone that disappeared right or just
you just didn't hear from right and
you're so it an extra could be linked to
someone like Tom Cruise from that movie
you want an Oscar for that movie you're
working with him you think he could at
least have maybe just called
I I was also
inflictedly linked to Cameron Crowe I
was linked to James L Brooks but I'm
also linked to people that I'm working
with now no I get it but do you get it
because it's like I get it you want to
know the dirt about it but to me no no
I'm not genuinely I'm not after any dirt
I guess your thing your response when I
mentioned Tom Cruise is
name actually you looked at me like you
were a bit hurt you hadn't heard from
him it's the thing where anyone that
shows you support is somebody that
you're going to gravitate towards the
people in my life now what do you think
about those who don't the people that
are in my eye watch yourself the people
in my life now uh Joe Callahan who
created this technology for view it uh
Danny Rodriguez is a crypto entrepreneur
to the nth degree created the show for
me called Tycoon that we're going into
production
uh oh no no over really no that's two
that's two I can't wait to hear number
three I remember you did the butler with
I've I've done a few projects with her
yeah not heard a word it's it's one of
those things Pierce where I I gotta be
honest I'm really not off to you I'm not
after any anything at all from you about
it I just suddenly thought with the two
people I know because I interviewed you
around the time of the butler yeah I
know how big Oprah was and supportive at
the time when things were good same with
Tom Cruise it's just it's interesting to
me these two superstars when someone is
really going through the worst time of
their life
can't even pick a phone up but is it the
worst time of my life really I mean it
was one of those times that you get
through I think my father's death was
probably a little bit harder right
so it's now I I can't sit and dwell on
that I gotta move forward with the
Positive Pierce I have to it's my life
where'd you keep your Austria
you wanna
I'm kidding I I have it in storage I
told you I removed yeah I moved from LA
to the east coast and and now I've just
been traveling with the viewet team what
do you think about that moment I mean
that must I assume that was a career
high for you yeah and I remember the
moment I loved the movie and it was just
a great moment of Joy yeah for you and
joy for your family enjoy for everyone
that knew you yeah and I mentioned in
the moment when you win an Oscar
everyone gravitates to you you become
like a magnet to people yeah and that's
why I'm just curious about the flip side
that when yeah but she just said it you
just said it everybody comes like a
magnet to you a magnet everywhere I go
and I want it I still want it I am I
will not ever let negativity stop the
god-given energy that I have than I've
had at the beginning of my career and
that's the simple truth Pierce there's
nothing else
and I know the projects that I'm working
on which I've explained to you I know
that not just the acting but the news on
the other business though but the acting
thing in particular because acting is
your real passion acting is what you're
great at doing right you know what my
real passion is to be honest with you I
directed a movie right
I mean I'd rather direct than act would
you a hundred percent because you one
you you get this Village of people who
all are there to support your vision and
if your vision is something that they
all believe in they'll do whatever it
takes to get that Vision made and and
you know I've been writing I have a
writing partner now
um
Todd machino and I have been working on
several uh uh not only features but
limited series and whatnot and um
and we're excited about it to get back
in the in the directing chair and in
front of the screen what have you found
out about yourself throughout this whole
five-year process
uh good and bad yeah
um
that I could be a bit much my energy can
be a bit much for people
um and and anyone can say anything in
this like you said this climate so you
have to be more aware you have to be
more
cognizant of not only what you say you
do in your actions and I I believe that
what have you discovered about yourself
you didn't like that you've changed
ah you know the partying was you know
it's a bit much I mean it's it's one of
those things where
you you want to numb that my mom told me
a long time ago don't numb the pain feel
the pain but when there was so much of
it I had to numb it and it felt good so
when you continually to do that you
forget to feel life again is your
ex-wife been supportive gee oh 100
everybody in my everybody in my campus
stood by me to get through this moment
in time and now it's my job to make sure
that my personal new and improved model
helps those some people say that when
you know I've spoken to people who've
been to prison yeah I mean did you have
a fear at one stage that might happen to
you no no I I and even
I mean if you look at any of these uh
allegations they're they're misdemeanors
and it was one of those to be guilty
I'm assuming that your legal advice
would have been look don't take a risk
that you might get imprisoned take a
plea deal that's normally why all of the
headlines is like he avoids jelly points
and it was like it was not my frame of
mind to avoid jail my frame of mind I
understand but he wants to admit guilt
to the truth of what happened right
right I mean but if you hadn't admitted
it you could have faith jail right if I
hadn't admitted I would have taken all
of those women to trial and they would
have had to
live this bile that I lived they would
have had to live again and from that
moment I was in that woman abused
shelter I said never do that to a woman
I would never put a woman through that
and
that's why I'm here
I mean you did put at least one moment
through that because you missed it
yeah 100 you put it through something
that she 100 was very offended by I
agree have you ever reached out to her
have you ever written tour
I mean I spoke to her and everyone there
in that courtroom when I gave my apology
and it was sincere yeah I think so
you know it's it's one of those things
in life where you have to focus on the
positive but not ignore who you are
where you've come from
you know it's it but do you live in the
past well it's gonna say to you or do
you have fear for the future something
at the moment right so some people say
I'm only cutting you off because cut me
up I see it was a two-way street I don't
want to cut you no I'm saying no fair
enough you'll see me go off I actually
you triggered a thought process in me
which I I should have let you finish but
the point I was going to make was on
that point I know people who've been to
prison and stuff yeah and they almost
always say that the worst moment to them
was the kind of moment of of exposure of
what they're accused of doing and but
actually everything after that was easy
to deal with including going to prison
actually that there's a kind of moment
of Reckoning when you know you can see
what's going to happen to you right and
that's the abyss moment yeah you come
out of it slowly but surely yeah are you
are you on that trajectory having
admitted what you did oh 100 and taking
your punishment do you feel now you're
on a trajectory out of this because I
mean only last week you had another case
where you had to pay 80 000 to a former
bartender you said that you groped it in
a man had nightclub that was because you
didn't turn up to Avengers I I didn't I
didn't I could have went and said look
at the video and put her through that
again and I just figured well why
wouldn't you do that to clear your name
because it's such a stain to have on
your record right and you know that
lesson you right now have already made
this theme of this cancel culture that
we're in right now and the only way for
me to reconcile that is to be honest and
truthful with who I am right and then
let you decide where you stand on on my
situation and that's all I can do here
would you rather pay 80 000 to not turn
up at something to defend yourself or
get in there and defend yourself well
the logistics of that also was the fact
that as you know in other people who've
went and testified and did depositions
for
um civil cases that is used against you
in a criminal case so it wasn't anything
I was gonna like you said the jail thing
push and prod the D.A to focus on that
so it was one of those things where I
was like it's better to do you have
thought about the possibility of jail
yeah in that instance a hundred percent
you're absolutely when you've had to
think about that how has that made you
feel it's one of those things where if
that's the path then that's the path I'm
on that would have been I mean
a real nadir for your life wouldn't it I
mean this is from winning an Oscar to a
prison cell yeah yeah I get it when you
when you thought about that
tell me about that I even thought about
that really a hundred percent you just
basically said you did no no I said the
technicality because you remember you
talked to lawyers and they say here's
the repercussions but it isn't the thing
I left the meeting and I went oh wow
what though I just don't I don't allow
myself those are insecurities and
thoughts of darkness and I don't let
darkness my producing partner that I
talk all the time you stay focused on
the positivity because it is what it is
so you're gonna choose your path where
do you hope to be in like 10 years time
uh would you like to have made another
movie for example I I would like to uh
uh yeah done a lot of things you know
that I keep kind of nibbling into to
explain to you but it's it's uh
yeah I'd like to just continue growth
period I need to see my kids grow and
become successful if Tom Cruise Tom
Cruise are watching this interview
so you narrowed it down to those two
well honey because they they are all of
my co-stars I love uh from them to Sarah
Paulson to anyone I've ever worked but
just for that benefit you haven't
changed your number oh 100 I never have
never will so they know how to get hold
of you a hundred percent would you like
them to I like everybody to get a hold
of me
it would mean a lot to you
what's your own narrative I'm just
awesome don't cry Roy
no but it's it's a big deal I I know
it's a big deal when people yeah support
or don't yeah yeah it means something to
you yeah I I I have to stand
ready to support those I love even if
that means
that I feel that I didn't feel the
support from them I still I'm here not
going anywhere but you wouldn't mind if
they called you yeah that'd be
phenomenal Cuba thank you very much
indeed of course thank you that's all
from me tonight on Piers organizer
remember whatever you're up to Keep It
Uncensored good night